hello my name is vadim
and i would like to demonstrate how to
visualize our complicated data easily
i'm glad to show you tauberbine for the
platform start page firstly we need to
go to data integration and modeling zone
when we choose manifold utilities
section now we are on the page where we
can process our data set with one of
manifold learning approach here we can
choose
the type of
data set
it can be
object futures table
or distance matrix for graph
which will be used as pre-computing
graph for our manifold method let's get
object features table for mice
expression dataset and upload it into
platform
if you already know
about classes of our samples
when we can upload table with this
information tool or if you don't know
about it
we can skip this step with this button
in this data set
each row it is expression values of
70
proteins
the classes should be written
in the following form
first column
ids of samples
second column
classes
[Music]
okay now we are ready to choose the
approach
which we would like to use
let's try umap
this page shows us a small
description of method
and it parameters
advanced users can change all of these
parameters
each parameter has description
[Music]
which you can get by hovering the mouse
over eye icon near
parameter name
newbies in manifold join can save
default parameters
and move to the next step
we press save button
i am filling the
name of
our pipeline
expression
now
our simple pipeline is ready to start
let's run it
we need to wait for a little time
for the pipeline to finish
ready
then click download pipeline output
files
and choose
a png picture of our data manifold
embedding visualization
or you can choose
this txt file with the points
coordinates
let's check a visualization
great your map approach works
we can see dividing of samples into two
clusters
control samples and threesome samples